it's that time again here's every
mechanic explained from tarir Dragon
storm there are six new mechanics one
new card type and we'll do a quick rules
refresher for a set of symbols we
haven't seen in 17 years let's jump into
it starting off with the clan mechanics
each of the five Clans has their own
mechanic let's start off with the Aban
Clan they have inure Ure is a keyword
action that you can find stapled to
abilities on creatures as we can see on
the latest good boy Fortress King guard
endure X means put X+ one plus one
counters on the creature with this
ability or create an XX white Spirit
token repeatable ways to grow creatures
or create a small army are nothing to
bulk at especially with the new eleth
storm Slayer that has anointed
procession stapled onto it
for Jess Sky it's being kept really
simple flurry is a triggered ability
that triggers when you cast your second
spell as seen on devoted jewelist in
their case when you cast your second
spell it deals one damage to each
opponent a couple of things to note
about this ability firstly it doesn't
care about what happened to your first
spell of the turn it may have resolved
or it may have been countered it could
even still be on the St stack all that
matters is you cast one when you cast
your second spell this ability will be
placed on the stack above your second
spell and it will resolve first so keep
that in mind moving on to the suai clan
we have renew an activated ability that
appears on creatures that let you pay a
cost and Exile that creature from your
graveyard in order to put some counters
on creatures as a sorcery for example on
Cari Revenant you can pay three to Exile
it from your graveyard to put a flying
counter a death touch counter and a
LifeLink counter on a creature you
control there are some renew cards with
bonus abilities like the one on Naga
flesh crafter when you renew it it puts
a plus one plus one counter on target
non- legendary creature and then all
other creatures you control become a
copy of that creature I'm sure turning
your army of one one otter into an army
of eyeballs won't be an issue for mardu
we have mobilize a triggered ability
that summons attacking one ones mobilize
says as featured on the commander card
zergo storm render mobilize X whenever
this creature attacks create X tapped
and attacking one one red Warrior
creature tokens sacrifice them at the
beginning of the next next end step this
ability doesn't seem too powerful on
paper but when you start pairing these
abilities with Anthem effects like War
leaders call newcomer allout assault an
elth or even standard staple caretaker's
Talent these abilities can really start
getting out of hand it's also worth
pointing out that unlike something like
Myriad which Exiles the tokens at the
end of combat the tokens from mobilized
stick around until the end of the turn
one important rules note to remember
with this ability is that the tokens
enter tapped and attacking so they don't
trigger any whenever a creature attacks
abilities because they weren't declared
as attackers the last of the clan
abilities is from teamer and I think
this will be the best one harmonize
harmonize is like a combination of
flashback and convoke
harmonize is an alternative cost that
lets you cast the card from a graveyard
just like flashback however you can tap
a creature and reduce the harmonized
cost by the creature's power here we can
see the mechanic on winternight stories
a three cost spell that says draw three
cards then discard two unless you
discard a creature you can then cast it
from your graveyard for a single blue
Mana if you just tape a creature you
control with power four or more don't
forget the creature you tap can be a
creature you just played so don't worry
about Summoning Sickness getting double
value from spells is always worthwhile
the last mechanic for this set is a nice
easy one behold some casts ask you to
Behold a dragon in order to get an
additional effect for example the one on
sakan Dragon ascendant when they enter
you may Behold a dragon if you do create
a treaure
token in this case to Behold a dragon
you simply choose a dragon you already
have in play or reveal one from your
hand now while the official rules
haven't been released yet at the time of
recording I'm pretty sure you have to
announce your behold like this to your
opponents
behold my
staff moving on to a new card type we
have Omen Omens are a sub type of
instance and sorceries and feature on
creatures similar to Adventure cards
from
elrain when you go to cast a card with
Omen you either choose to cast it as the
creature in which case you ignore the
text box in the bottom left or you can
choose to cast it as The Omen in which
case you ignore the creature part of the
card when the omen resolves you Shuffle
the card back into your
library there are some important things
to note with these sorts of cards while
on the stack the spell has the
characteristics of the half you've
chosen to cast for example if you cast
the absorb Essence Omen of purging storm
brood your opponent couldn't Essence
scatter it but they definitely could
spell snare it and while these cards are
in your graveyard hand or Library it
only has the characteristics of the
creature half so you wouldn't be able to
cast solve the equation and find Claim
territory the final mechanic I wanted to
talk about is a returning one hybrid
Mana now it's been 17 years since we
last saw these exact Mana symbols in the
casting cost of a spell so I thought it
was worth going over the rules for these
cards with hybrid Mana symbols you can
choose to pay each of the Pips of the
cost in whichever way you like you can
either pay two Mana of any type or one
Mana of the pictured color so for
example with gur mag night watch you
could either pay six Mana of any type or
you could pay four Mana of any type and
one green Mana or you could pay one
green one black and one blue Mana or any
other combination one big thing to note
with hybrid cost spells their Mana value
is equal to the largest cost that could
be paid for the spell so the converted
Mana cost for for River wheel sweep is
six not three no matter how much money
you paid to cast a spell the other thing
to keep in mind is that the spell still
has the color identity of the colors
that feature in the Pips so Monastery
messenger is still a blue red and white
card even if you only spent six green
Mana to cast it now if you have any
questions about anything I've covered
here let me know in the comments down
below be sure to like the video If you
learned something and subscribe because
if you don't you'll never hit natural
Tron again to cast the new ugan on turn
three thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one